- Allo, Johanna. Ça va bien?
- Oui.
- nnnnnna nous accueille chez
elle, à Chilliwack. Elle vient
tout juste de rentrer à la
maison, six jours après avoir
été évacuée.
JOHANNA KUEMPER, résidente
Chilliwack, C.-B.
- J'ai pas dormi. J'ai pas dormi
de la semaine, parce que cette
soirée-là, je me suis dit,
mon doux, j'avais dans ma tê,,,
je m'imaginais que ma maison
était inondée.
- Elle constate qu'elle a été
épargnée, comme lapapapart des
habitations dans son quartier,
d'ailleurs. Tous ici sont
soulagés.
- Est-ce que tu t'es amusé chez
des amis?
- À quelques pas de chez
Johanna, le niveau de l'eau a
cécécécé à diminuer, mais vous
le constatez autour de nous,
pas assez pour permettre
à tous ceux qui le souhaitent
de rentrer chez eux. Les terres
agricoles ici ressemblentdavante
sur laquelle on se trouve est
toujours impraticable.
L'eau recouvre la chaussée.
Ces fermes sont toujours
inaccessibles. Le retour à la
normale n'est pas pour bientôt.
Ce producteur laitier,
dont le terrain est surélevé,
a hébergé des vaches de fermes
avoisinantes pour les sauver..
Il ne sait pas pendant combien
de temps elles resteront ici.
Des milliers d'animaux sont
morts dans cette région
agricole,  p p p p pour
plusieurs éleveurs.
Maintenant, il faut réparer
ce que l'on peut réparer.
De nombreuses routes comme
celles-ci ont été morcelées par
les glissements de terrain.
- Je devais me dire, je répétais
souvent, c'est juste du bois.
C'est juste une maison.
C'est juste des choses.
Au moins, ma famille est en
sécurité puis on est ensemble
puis c'est ça qui compte.
- C'est ce que se rép
toujours ceux qui ne peuvent
qu'attendre, en espérant que la
pluie ne vienne pa